space invasion big car chase
truth be told I was ready to hang it up
to limit you today so you're not from
around here it's hard to explain
[Music]
I keep having these memories
I see flashes
[Music]
I think I had a life here
but I can't tell if it's real
[Music]
we have no idea what threats are out
there
we can't do this alone
we need you
[Music]
I'm not what you think I am
hey everybody its charlie we got brand
new Captain Marvel to break down Marvel
just revealed their new origin story for
her in advance of the movie coming out
they've completely changed her origin
story and it will totally change the way
you re watch the trailer and look at the
characters so I'll explain what's going
on the spider-man ps4 game giveaway is
still going on all you have to do to
enter that is be a subscriber and leave
a comment on the video I'll name a new
winner at the end of this so the whole
reason for Marvel to change her origin
story is they don't want it to feel like
the Green Lantern movie because
everybody hated that and they don't want
to have any kind of association with
that mentally or otherwise Brian
Reynolds takes every opportunity he can
to make fun of his Green Lantern movie
they even put that post-credits tag from
Deadpool at the end so I don't think
he's offended by any of this at all like
of course studios don't want to have
anything to do with that Green Lantern
movie
you're welcome Canada so in the original
version of events
the evil Crees scientist jaan raghav as
I keep a great Ron is a device to
experiment on people and give them
special powers this sounds familiar
because the creek also experimented on
humans millennia ago to try and create a
race of super-powered warriors to fight
for them in their ongoing wars against
the scrolls they became the Inhumans so
already Marvel has been plagiarizing
itself with character origins when it
came to miss Marvel Carol Danvers what
happened was is the original male
version of Captain Marvel named Marvel
tries to say Carol Danvers from yon brog
but during the conflict the psyche
Megatron explodes Marvel already has
cosmic powers and he's a pink skin Kree
has the appearance of a human in his
genetically compatible with humans he
tries to shield her from the blasts but
the reaction caused by the explosion
transfers some of his DNA to Carol
Danvers rewriting her genetic code
because remember pink skin Kree are
genetically compatible with humans
effectively transforming her into half
Kree and because now she has half of his
DNA
it also gives her Marvel's superpowers
making her Miss Marvel in the Marvel
Universe so you could see the
similarities and ovens are a crash
landing on planet earth and his ring
going to Hal Jordan transferring his
power so now what Marvel has done is
effectively changed everything you know
captain Marvel's family and how she came
to be on planet earth now her mother was
a captain of the creep Protectorate sent
to Planet Earth as a sleeper agent in a
precursor to galactic conquest she had
been trained since birth to be one of
the Crees most badass warriors and
become physically very powerful in her
own right when she's sort of explaining
captain Marvel's true history to her
like this is where I come from this is
why I'm so strong and such a badass
she says that creed adapt to training
differently than humans think of them as
the Klingons of the Marvel Universe war
is a way of life for them so the
stronger you are the more victorious you
are the more honor you have so her
mother becomes a bit of the most
fearsome respected warriors in the Kree
Empire it gets sent on this special
mission to Planet Earth
as you would expect she falls in love
with a human they get married they have
a daughter that daughter is Carol
Danvers so she's born half Kree already
and her mother never tells her her true
origin story so Carol Danvers grows up
thinking that she's just a totally
normal little girl on planet earth like
anybody else so what happens is is later
yon raagh the psyche magnetron accidents
still end up happening but what it does
is is that instead of giving her her
powers it only unlocks latent ability
that was already within her so it's very
similar to MCU Scarlet Witch the mind
gem didn't give Scarlet Witch her powers
it just unlocked latent abilities that
were already within her DNA which is
also consequently a basis for mutants
already existing in the MCU without
actually calling them mutants like
imagine the mind gem just turned on
Wanda's X gene the only difference with
Captain Marvel is is that she already
had a measure of genetic super powers
because of the Kree half of her DNA
so now Yuri watched the Captain Marvel
trailer that they released a little
while ago with all those weird shots of
Jude Law and you think about the fact
that they haven't confirmed who he is
doesn't it make it much more likely now
that he's the true villain of the film
and it sort of recontextualizes why you
see her on the Kree homeworld here
instead of it feeling like a conspiracy
theory people lying to her about who she
really is she actually does feel
genuinely like a person of two different
worlds
imagine if Worf from Star Trek were
genetically half-human he would
raised by humans so he knows their
customs but in his heart he feels this
pull of the Klingon Empire so there's
this two halves to himself that are
always at war with each other I would
say Spock is a better example but
because Captain Marvel is one of the
punchiest Pheidias stabia steel heroes
Worf is probably a better analogy just
because of his personality so all this
stuff that you see in the trailer with
her fighting with Star Force for the
Kree Empire makes a lot more sense now
because she is half Kree that's her
ancestral home even though her birth
home is Earth and when she says in the
trailer I think I had a life here I'm
not who you think I am it makes a whole
lot more sense and it gives her a better
internal conflict for whether or not she
feels loyalty to what's happening on
planet Earth like if Earth isn't her
ancestral home why should she care about
it as much as she cares about the Kree
homeworld it's just a much more
compelling conflict for her to deal with
internally while all this external stuff
is going on with the Skrulls let me know
in the comments though what do you think
about this new version of her origin
story the only thing that's missing from
it is the original version of Captain
Marvel Marvel I don't know what they're
gonna do with him I don't think they
would completely retcon him out of
Marvel Comics so he's probably in there
somewhere but a lot of people have now
theorized that what they might do is
just combine the original Marvel in the
yawn draw Erik ters and give them a
single persona in that's really what's
going on with Jude Law so he's both the
villain but also something of a mentor
to her before she figures out what's
really going on there's a lot more
Marvel movie stuff going on that I'll
try to do videos for daredevil season 3
is premiering I'll do videos for that
but leave all your requests in the
comments below
congratulations top flight your the
giveaway winner from my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
click here for that new spider-man far
from home teaser and click here to learn
all about when the Avengers 4 trailer is
coming and listen to Tom Hiddleston talk
about Loki thank you so much for
watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]